there is no quick technical fix Tobias
it's really tempting to want to think
that there's going to be some type of
silver bullet solution that we can just
tweak our algorithms or you know use
different sorts of training data sets or
try to boost signal in particular ways
the problem of this is that it really
doesn't look to the deep social and
historical issues that human data is
made from you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen Hughes
Inga
artificial intelligence has captured our
imagination and made many things we
would have thought impossible only a few
years ago seem commonplace today but AI
has also raised some challenging issues
for society writ large enter dr. Kate
Crawford a principal researcher at the
New York City Lab of Microsoft Research
dr. Crawford along with an illustrious
group of colleagues in computer science
engineering social science business and
law has dedicated her research to
addressing the social implications of AI
including big topics like bias labor and
automation rights and liberties and
ethics and governance today dr. Crawford
talks about both the promises and the
problems of AI why when it comes to data
bigger isn't necessarily better and how
even in an era of increasingly complex
technological advances we can adopt AI
design principles that empower people to
shape their technical tools in ways
they'd like to use them most that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
welcome Kate Crawford to the podcast
great to have you here with us from New
York City thank you so much Gretchen
it's a pleasure to be here
so you're in the as we've said New York
City lab of Microsoft research what goes
on in the Big Apple oh so much it's the
city that doesn't sleep when are we so
just concerned look there's so much
going on here it is actually we have an
abundance of exciting research
initiatives obviously here we have the
Microsoft Research New York office and
in here we have sort of four groups writ
large we have a really fantastic machine
learning group we have a computational
social science group we have an
algorithmic economics group and we have
the Fate group which is a group that I
co-founded with my colleagues
Hannah Wallach and Fernando Diaz and it
stands for fairness accountability
transparency and ethics and that group
is coming into its third year now we
really early on saw that there were
going to be some real concerns around
ensuring that large-scale
decision-making systems were producing
fair results and fair predictions and we
also needed to start thinking much more
about accountability for decision making
particularly in relation to machine
learning and artificial intelligence and
of course ethics which is a very broad
term that communal sorts of things for
us it means really looking at how people
are affected by a whole range of
technologies that are now touching our
lives be that in criminal justice or
education or in health care so that was
the reason we formed the fake group here
in New York in addition to what's
happening here at MSI and we see there
are also other groups there's data and
Society which is headed by Dana Boyd and
just around the corner from this
building and then in way.you we have a
brand new research institute that I
co-founded with Meredith Whitaker called
the AI now Institute and that's the
first University Institute to focus on
the social implications of artificial
intelligence so there's a lot going on
in New York right now I'll say you know
I want to ask you some specific
questions about a couple of those things
that you mentioned but
droolin a little bit on what
computational social science means yeah
I'm that group is headed by Duncan watts
and realistically they are looking at
large-scale data to try and make sense
of particular types of patterns so you
know what can you learn about how a city
is working when you look at traffic
flows for example one of the ways in
which you could contextualize people's
search information in order to give them
different types of data that could help
I mean there are lots of things that the
CSS group does here in New York well
let's go back to fate because that's
kind of a big interest of yours right
now
fairness accountability transparency and
ethics and you sort of gave us an
overview of why you started the group
and it's fairly nascent is it having an
impact already is it having any impact
that you'd hoped for in the high-tech
industry absolutely we've been really
thrilled I mean even though it's only
three years old in some ways that's
actually quite established for thinking
about these issues I've been as a
researcher focusing on questions around
fairness and due process in some
large-scale data systems and machine
learning for over ten years but it's
really only been in the last 18 months
or so that we've seen this huge uptick
in interest across both academia and
industry so we're starting to see
algorithmic accountability groups emerge
in kind of the key technology companies
here in the US we also have conferences
like the fat ml conference which stands
for fairness accountability and
transparency you guessed it which has
now become a blockbuster hit it's
actually taking place here in New York
City in just two weeks
to a full house and an extensive waiting
list so it's really actually taking off
but we are also seeing it really start
to have impact within microsoft itself I
mean here Hannah and myself for example
and various product groups who are
coming up with questions where they
think a system might produce say a
discriminatory output what should they
do or they might have concerns with the
data that a system has been trained on
what sorts of questions might you want
to ask including all the way through to
what are the big policy questions that
we need to ask here and we're doing
things like speaking to the European
Commission to the UN etc so and for a
small group it's just four of us I think
it's already having a pretty
outsized impact interesting that you say
you've been doing this for about ten
years which i think is surprising to a
lot of people with the machine learning
coming to the forefront now why do you
think only in the last 18 months have we
seen an uptick I think has a lot to do
with scale I mean what's particularly
interesting to me is that just in the
last actually about three months we've
seen leaders from major technology
companies including such an adela
including one of the cofounders of deep
mind Mustafa Suleiman and the head of
Google AI all say that fairness and bias
were the key challenges for the next
five years so it's gone from being
something that was a relatively bespoke
concern shall we say to becoming front
of mind for all of the sort of leaders
of the major technology companies and I
think the reason why and certainly the
reason that Mustafa gave when he was
sort of making his statement about this
is because if you have a system that's
producing a discriminatory result say
for example in search or in ads that is
affecting a billion to two billion users
a day easily so at that scale that can
be extremely costly and extremely
dangerous for the people who are subject
to those decisions so yeah I think in
that sense it's a really a question of
how many people can be affected by these
sorts of systems given their truly vast
reach
[Music]
you recently gave a talk at the nips
conference neural information processing
systems and the talk was called the
trouble with bias what is the trouble
with by escape well this is an amazing
conference I should say out of the gate
it was a real honor to speak there it is
in fact the largest machine learning
conference in the world I was speaking
in this room as the sort of opening
keynote to around 8,000 people so it
kind of felt like being at a at a van
Halen concert or something extremely
stadium rock it was extraordinary to see
but I was really interested to talk
about what's been happening with this
concept of bias and I looked at
particularly some of the cases that
we've seen emerge and that have been
interesting to researchers so for
example everything from if you do search
in Bing or in Google for CEO and you do
an image search you'll find a lot of
images of men in suits and depending on
which way the algorithm is blowing that
day the first woman that you'll see is
quite often CEO Barbie so it raises very
troubling questions about how we
represent gender and then of course
there are a whole series of studies
coming out now looking at how we
represent race and here we look at
anything from the way that training data
set like labelled faces in the wild is
around 79% male and 84% white so they're
the sorts of populations that systems
that are trained on labelled faces in
the world will perform best for so
that's in the space of facial
recognition but what I was talking about
at nips was really sharing brand new
research that I've been working on with
Sol and Baracus at Cornell and Hannah
Wallach here at Microsoft Research and
Aaron Shapiro at UPenn where we're
looking at the way that bias in computer
science has traditionally been looked at
and basically the way that it's been
studied so far we did a big analysis of
all the papers is it really looks at the
types of harms that caused a type of
economic or what we call allocative harm
so it means that a system is determined
to be biased if you don't get a job or
if it decides that you don't get bail or
a few can get access to credit but
there's a whole range of other high
which we call representational homes
which doesn't mean that you don't
necessarily get a job but it might mean
that this is just a denigration of a
particular category or community let's
talk for a minute about the data sets
that actually train our AI models as far
as the data goes we're often told that
bigger is better but what you just said
suggests this might not be the case can
you explain how bigger data isn't
necessarily better data yeah I mean
there has been I think this perception
for some time now that the more data we
have the more representative it is but
that's simply not the case if you are
over sampling from a particular
population we could think about here you
know say for example Twitter data there
was a period say 5 years ago when people
really thought Twitter data was going to
be the best way to understand what was
happening during a natural disaster or a
humanitarian crisis but it was very very
clear from early on and certainly in
some work that I was doing many years
ago that showed just how skewed the
demographics are of people who are using
Twitter at that time let alone people
who have access to smartphones so
depending where you are in the world
that means it's not particularly a very
reliable signal so even if you have
hundreds of thousands of data points if
all of those data points are being drawn
from affluent populations who live in
urban centers then you're only seeing
one part of the picture and it's going
to be extremely difficult for you to
extrapolate from that and there are
various related problems with training
data right now training data is you know
often comes from sets that have hundreds
of thousands if not millions of
particular items within them but if they
are very particularly sampled from an
already skewed hmm Hall then that's
gonna still produce results I mean there
have been some really you know
interesting examples I think that we can
look at here and they come from all
sorts of interesting places in the case
of you know criminal justice there's
been a lot of controversy around the use
of the compass risk assessment system
which essentially tries to predict a
risk score for whether or not somebody
will rear fenders a violent criminal but
of course it's you know trained on data
that is historical crime data and again
many criminologists and social
scientists point to the fact that there
is a long history of racist policing in
the u.s. so if you're already
from a baseline where people of color
and low-income communities are far more
likely to be stopped by the police to be
arrested by the police didn't beat
generally surveilled they will be
over-represented in those samples and
then if you're training a system on that
data how do you actually accommodate
that these are really hard questions and
I think what I've certainly learned from
looking at these questions as a
researcher is that there is no quick
technical fix to bias it's really
tempting to want to think that there's
going to be some type of silver bullet
solution that we can just tweak our
algorithms or you know use different
sorts of training data sets or try to
boost signal in particular ways the
problem of this is that it really
doesn't look to the deep social and
historical issues that human data is
made from that essentially data reflects
our human history and our human history
itself has many many instances of bias
so I think what's so interesting and
when I talk about the trouble with bias
is that I think particularly in computer
science we tend to scope the problem to
nerely and to think of it purely as
something that we can address
technically I think it's incredibly
important that we understand it as a
socio technical problem that means
addressing these sorts of issues very
much in an interdisciplinary context so
if you're designing a system that is
doing anything to do with the criminal
justice system you should be working
side by side with people who have been
doing the most important work in those
fields
this pertains to every one of the
domains of healthcare education criminal
justice policing you name it you know I
have area experts who I think you've
just been to this point kind of left out
of those development cycles and we
really need them in the room well I
think there's been a misconception first
of all that data doesn't lie and it can
if you have you know sitting populations
that you're only representing but also
this idea of the sort of separation of
church and state between technology and
the humanities or Technology and social
science and so what I'm hearing not just
from you but over and over is we have to
start talking cross-pollinating silo
busting whatever you want to call it to
solve some of these bigger problems yeah
absolutely I couldn't agree more I mean
this was really one of the big
motivations behind establishing the I
know
Institute you was that we realize we
really needed to create a university
center that was inviting people from all
disciplines to come and collaborate on
these sorts of questions and
particularly in terms of issues around
you know bias and fairness but even more
broadly in terms of things like labor
and automation and the future of work
right through to what happens when we
start applying machine learning to
critical infrastructure like the power
grid or to hospitals in order to answer
any of those questions you kind of need
a really deep bench of people from very
different disciplines and we ended up
trying to address that by working with
six different faculties and centers to
establish AI now so it's a co-production
if you will between computer science
engineering social science business and
law as well as the Center for data
science really because I think you need
all those people there to really make it
work let's switch to another topic for a
bit and that is this concept of
autonomous experimentation with the
proliferation of sensors and massive
amounts of data gathering people may not
be aware much of the time that they are
in fact data and not necessarily what
their knowledge or consent can you speak
to that oh absolutely I mean and I
should say the an autonomous
experimentation research that we've been
doing here is very much a collaborative
project which has been work that I've
been doing along side people like Hannah
Wallach and Fernando Diaz and Sarah Byrd
and it's been really fascinating to
essentially look at how a series of new
systems that are really being deployed
far more widely than people realize
they're actually doing forms of
automated experimentation in real time
and we were looking at a range of
systems including say what happens when
you use a traffic app using a mapping
app that saying hey where is the traffic
bad where is it good the way these
systems are working is that they're
essentially constantly running
experiments large-scale experiments
often on hundreds of thousands of people
simultaneously and this can be good in
many cases it's for things like you know
load balancing where people go if we all
got the same directions to go to you
know say downtown Manhattan from uptown
and then the roads would be unusable
they would be completely congested so
you kind of have to load balance between
different pallets but what that also
means is that some people will always be
allocated to the less ideal condition
set of that experiment and some will be
allocated to the ideal conditions end
which means that you know you might be
getting the fastest way to get to work
that day and somebody else will be
getting a slightly slower way and now
this sounds absolutely fine when you're
thinking about you know perhaps if
you're just going to work in a few
minutes either side it's and ruin your
day but what if you're going to hospital
what if you have a sick kid in the back
of your car and it's really urgent that
you get to a hospital how can you say no
I really don't want to be allocated into
the less ideal group or this could
happen as well on health apps you know
how can you indicate that in
experimentation which has been used to
try and say make you jog more or do more
exercise that you're somebody who's
recovering from an injury or somebody
who has a heart condition these are the
sorts of issues that really indicated to
us that it's important that we start
doing more work on feedback mechanisms
on what are the sorts of consent
mechanisms that we can think about when
people are being allocated into
experiments often without their
knowledge this is very common now we're
kind of getting used to the fact that
ABB experiments at scale really began
with search but now they're really
moving and submerging into much more
intimate systems that guide our everyday
lives from anything that you're using on
your phone about your health or your
engagements with friends right through
to you know how you spend your time so
how do we start to think about the
consent mechanisms around
experimentation that was the real
motivation behind those series of
ongoing studies well and it does speak
to this dichotomy between
self-governance and government
regulation mm-hm and because we're in
kind of a Wild West phase of AI lot of
things haven't caught up yet however the
European Union has the gdpr that does
attempt to address some of these issues
what is your thinking on whether we go
with our own oversight who's watching
the watchdog kind of thing or invite
regulations what's going on in your mind
about that it's such a good question
it's an incredibly complex question and
unfortunately there are no easy answers
here I mean certainly GDP
comes into effect in May this year and I
think it's going to be extraordinarily
interesting to see what happens as it
begins to be rolled out certainly a lot
of the technology companies have been
doing a lot of work to think about how
their products are going to change in
terms of what they're offering right but
it will also be interesting to see if it
has flow on effects to other parts of
the world like the US and a whole range
of other countries that aren't covered
by GDP are well the interesting thing
for me is that say the European Union
has it it has far-reaching tentacles
right it's not just for Europe it's for
anyone who does business with Europe and
it does as you say represent a very
complex question it does I mean I think
about this a lot in terms of artificial
intelligence writ large and that term
can be many things so I'm using it here
to really refer to not just sort of
machine learning based systems but a
whole range of other technologies that
fit under the AI banner and this is
something that is going to have enormous
impacts over the next ten years and
there's a lot of attention being paid to
what are the types of regulatory
infrastructures what are the types of
state and corporate pressures on these
sectors and how is it going to change
the way that people are judged by these
systems as we know China has a social
credit score some people find this quite
a disturbing system but there are many
things in the u.s. that are not
dissimilar so we're already moving quite
rapidly into a state where these systems
are being used to have direct impacts on
people's lives and I think there's going
to be a lot of questions that we have to
ask about how to ensure that that is
ethical and I think equitable right and
that is where interestingly I think some
good research could be happening both on
the technical side and the social
science side as we address these and all
of the sort of expertise and disciplines
that you talked about that are working
in the fate group
[Music]
so let's talk for a second about there's
so many questions I want to ask you Kate
and this is just not nearly enough time
so I'm coming to New York I'm gonna get
into that traffic there and and come see
you great you know listen the
overarching question for me right now is
about how do we take these big thorny
prickly questions issues and start to
address them practically what are your
thoughts on how we can maybe reassert or
recapture our agency in what I'd call a
get app world yeah I think that's a
really fascinating question I mean
what's interesting of course is how many
systems that touch our lives these days
that we don't even have a screen
interface for so many many major cities
you're walking down the street you know
your face is being recorded your
emotions are being predicted based on
your expressions that day you know your
geolocation is being tracked through
your phone these are all things that
don't involve any type of Commission
structure a screen or even you being
aware that you know your data and your
movements are being ingested by a
particular system so I think my concern
is that while more granular permission
based structures are possible urban
computing has shifted away from the
devices directly in front of us to be
embedded throughout architectures
throughout streets throughout so many
systems that are in many ways invisible
to us and they're already having a real
impact on how people are being assessed
and the sort of impacts that they might
experience and in just walking around a
city in a day so I think we are coming
up with things that would have been
great to have and would still be useful
in some contexts but they don't resolve
I think these much bigger questions
around what is agency when you are
really just at point amongst many many
other data points and being used by a
whole range of systems that are in many
ways completely opaque to you I think we
need to do a lot more work and so now to
agree with you I mean this is an urgent
area for research we just desperately
need more people working in these areas
both technically and I think on this
these more social science perspective
you know it's funny as you're speaking
Cape you actually just identified
basically a generation
GIP as it were you know like if a
country doesn't have landline phone
infrastructure and goes straight to cell
phones right and so just when we're
thinking we ought to be more cognizant
about giving consent to apps and
technologies you're bringing up the
excellent point that there's so much
going on that we don't even get asked
for constantly and also I mean there's
another thing here I think that we've
really moved beyond the discussion of
you know the idea of a single person you
know looking at an app and deciding
whether or not you should allow it to
have access to all of your contacts
we're in a very different state where
you could be using an app or a system
and you're thinking that you're it's for
one thing but it's actually doing
something else I mean that the classic
case here is say you know sort of the
Pokemon go crazy where you're out to
sort of capture all pokemons in a sort
of augmented reality environment in
cities but that became a was being used
to harvest a massive training data set
to really generate sort of new maps and
geo-located data so people in some ways
think that they're doing one thing but
their data is being used to Train
employee different type of system that
you know they may have no idea about so
I think again this idea that we're even
aware of what we're participating in I
think has really moved on
yeah again with the idea that we're on a
podcast and no one can see me shaking my
head this does bring up questions about
the practical potential solutions that
we have is there any from your end any
recommendation not just about what the
problems are but who should be tackling
them and how I mean yeah absolutely I'm
actually I mean for a while well our
conversation does cover some really
thorny and I think quite confronting
questions that we're going to need to
contend with as researchers and as an
industry I think that there's also a lot
of hope and there's a lot that we can do
one of the things that I work on at they
I now Institute as we release an annual
state of a I report and in the report we
make a series of recommendations every
year and in the last report which just
came out a couple of months ago we
really sort of made some very clear and
direct recommendations about how to
address some of these core problems one
of them is that we just
that you know before releasing an AI
system particularly the high stakes
domain so all of those things we've
chatted about like you know healthcare
Colonel Justice education that companies
should be running rigorous pre-release
trials to ensure that those systems
aren't going to amplify you know errors
and biases and I see that as a fairly
basic request I mean it's certainly
something we expect of you know
pharmaceutical drugs before they go on
the market that they've been tested that
they won't cause harm the same is true
of you know consumer devices ideally
they don't blow up you know with some
exceptions if you really want to make
sure that there's some pretty extensive
testing and trials and then trials that
can be sort of publicly shared that we
can say we have assessed that this
system you know doesn't produce
disparate impact on different types of
communities I think it's also really
important that another recommendation I
thing we can do is you know after
releasing these such sorts of complex
often you know algorithmically driven
systems should I say that we just
continue to monitor the use across the
different contexts and communities often
you know type of system is released and
it's a see that it's just going to work
for everybody
for an indefinite period of time it's
just not the case I was looking at a
study recently that suggested that
medical health data has a four-month
half-life that's four months before it
becomes out of date before the data in
that training dataset is actually going
to become contradicted by things that
have happened after the fact so we need
to keep thinking about how long is a
system relevant how might it be
performing differently for different
communities so this is another
recommendation that we feel very
strongly about but there are many more
and if people are interested in
particular types of research questions
or concrete steps that we can take
moving forward the AI now 2017 report
has a lot of those in there for more
reading yeah I would actually encourage
our listeners to get it and read it
because it is fascinating and it
addresses things from a sort of upstream
point of view which i think is where we
need to go we're a bit downstream
because we've released the Kraken in
many ways if they I it's like suddenly
they're hit in fact back to the original
you know the last 18 months I think part
of the reason may be that we're seeing
an increased interest is because people
are realizing hey this is happening and
it's happening to me and now I care
prior to that I just
you know kind of went along and didn't
pay attention so attention is a good
thing let me ask you this you mentioned
a concept from architecture called
desire lines in a ton I heard use I
loved it in the sense that it's like
shortcuts in public spaces where you
know find a path on the grass because
people don't want to go around on the
concrete and I would say things like
Napster and BitTorrent are sort of
examples of technical desire lines or
it's like I'm gonna go around is there
anything in that space that's sort of
happening now from a grassroots
perspective where we sort of take back
the night kind of thing
you know I think there is there are some
really nice examples of very small
grassroots efforts that have been
extremely successful in doing things
like essentially creating spaces of
anonymity where you're much more
protected from your data being harvested
for reasons that you may or may not have
agreed to even things like the private
messaging service signal which again was
created really by you know one guy and
furious friends and Moxie Marlinspike
has been I think very much a champion
that individuals can you know create
these types of systems that can create
more freedom and more agency for people
mm-hmm and there are others too I think
it's going to be interesting to think
about how that will happen in an AI
driven world and even I think in the
major technology companies I think it's
really important to create ways that
people can start to shape these tools
and the way that they'd most like to use
them and to give some space for a sort
of desire lines where you can say well I
don't actually want my AI assistant work
this way or I don't want it to have
access to this information but how can I
train it to do what I want it to do to
make it an advocate for me so rather
than serving the interests of you know
just a particular company and it's
really there as my agent as someone
who's going to look out for the things
that I care about these are things that
we can think of as design principles and
certainly something that people do talk
about a lot at Microsoft Research and
it's something that I think is really
exciting and inspiring for more work to
happen there I can't agree more it feels
like there's a call both to the
technical designers and makers and the
end users that need to say hey I need to
pay attention I can't just be lazy I
need to take agency I think that's
absolutely right Kate
we go what thoughts or advice would you
leave with our listeners many of whom
are aspiring researchers that might have
an interest in the social impact of AI
and I would say go broad on this for
both computer scientists social
scientists any kind of you know the
interdisciplinary crowd Wow well first
of all I'd say welcome you're actually
asking some of the most important
questions that can be asked right now in
the research world and it would be
amazing to see people really start to
dig into specific domain questions
specific tools and really start to say
you know what kind of world do we want
to be living in and how can our tools
best serve us there in terms of
resources that you can go to now they
really are some you know great
conferences even the big you know
machine learning conferences like nips
have workshops focus on things like
fairness and accountability we have the
fat ml conference which is annual but
there's also you know the AI now
conferences which happen every year and
a lot of I think discussion that's been
happening in a series of groups and
reading groups in various cities that
people can connect with and I just think
there's like a thriving research
community now that I'm certainly
starting to see grow very rapidly
because these questions are so pressing
so in essence I'd say you know
regardless of your field AI is going to
be changing the way we think and work
and that means that likely if you're a
researcher this is something you want to
start caring about and please if there
are ways that I can help or if people
want to get in touch they welcome to do
so Kate Crawford thank you for taking
time out of your schedule but like I
said I want to keep talking to you
forever such a pleasure thank you so
much Goshen it was great
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Crawford's work
on the social impacts of AI and to
download the most recent report from AI
now visit microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]